>> Butch: YOU KNOW HE'S GOING T
WORRIED ABOUT WINNING
ANDERS LEE SQUARES  THE
SEASON.
51 POINTS ON THE YEAR FORE ICE
BECAUSEDMAN.
DOBSON WAS THERE.
PAGEAU HIT OFF
HEDMAN IN GOALS AND POINTS
SIDETHAT.
CIRELLI LIFTED THE STICK OF
OUT.
DOBSON, BLOCKED HIM.
COULDN'T GET IT TO STICK.
KUCHEROV OVER.
BELLEMARE LOST IT.
IT'S IN!
>> Butch: THAT GOES OFF THE BODY
OPALAT.
REBOUND.
IT'S IN!
THERE'S TO STAMKOS.
HEDMAN BACK.
IT'S PERRY AND HE NG, BANG,
BANG.
DIDN'T HAVE TO PUT THAT
GREENE.
HAD SEVEN DEFENSEMEN DRESSED
TONIGHT FOR THE
SHOT WIDE.
BEAUVILLIER HAD PARISE GOING TO
THE NET.NCE FOR McDONAGH
ON THE REBOUND GOT  TOWARDS THE.
NOBODY JINXED HIM TOO. SHOOTS TE
YEAR.
PALAT RACING AHEAD.
BAILEY THE ONLY ONE BACK.
PALAT
THE ISLANDERS TRYING TO
THEY SCORE!
PARISE G GIT.
I'M NOT SURE THAT ANYBODYY
SCORES.
SO THERE WILL BE NO MAGNIFICENT